[Music]
joining me today is an author a
screenwriter the host of the Andrew
Clavin show and one of the few sane
people on the Internet
Andrew Clavin welcome back to the Reuben
report thank you it's nice to be here I
love your new studio thanks well you
were one of the last guests before we
built this home studio and we had you on
at a very odd time because it was right
before the election but we were going to
air it after the election because I had
to pad some shows because I were we were
building this so I and perhaps you two
went on the assumption that Hilary was
going to win and and then people
immediately after we aired it said you
got to get Clavin back on because you
guys got it got to clean this whole
thing up so you ready to do some
cleaning I'm ready I'm here all right so
where was our first I do consider you
one of the few same people that I that
speaks ill of you yeah but I can Sicily
every time I watch one of your clips or
I see what you're tweeting about you
strike me as just you basically strike
me as decent which these days I think
has a correlation between decency and
sanity that's a lot of pressure I'm
giving you know it is sad that being
decent actually elevates you love the
concern these days but but you know it's
the thing with me is that I have I can
say I can state what my principles are I
can I try to follow my principles I try
not to get too mixed up with
personalities which in this day and age
with a president like Trump with like
the people around you around him makes
things a lot clearer you know because
that's what people are paying attention
to they're paying attention to the big
faces the paying attention to that he
said this and she said that and I'm just
like trying to follow that principle
would I know what it is and I'm trying
to follow that thing yeah so I think I
come from a similar place and I think
you know our politics which do line up
in a lot of ways not not fully but that
that's what I try to go for where do you
think that comes from within you that
you don't go for all that other stuff
that that's so many people are you well
in me it's actually a matter of time
observing over time what works what
doesn't work and also you know it's just
been a basic maybe it was the time I was
raised in but has been a basic principle
of me that people
mind that people should be free that you
should be free that you are you know
made by God to be a free person that the
things that are happening inside you
that are expressed in your and the
things that you like and the things that
you want to say and your opinions on
that all those things are uniquely
valuable and even if you're a jackass
even if you're saying stuff that makes
me want to strangle you you know if
you're a racist or something like this I
think that there's something uniquely
valuable about that and I know that it's
more important than some guy in
Washington who knows better than you and
I think the text that's always been my
assumption it was I was raised in that
all-american way I was raised in the
suburbs in the early sixties you know
it's just that was kind of what that was
a civic religion and it always seemed
good to me and when things changed I
would listen to the arguments and I
found you know I've developed and that
things get are different over time but
certain principles stay the same and if
you stick with that you basically I
don't know you know it's a question of
actually enjoying other people and even
when they can be jerks sometimes I like
them you know I'd like yeah you can
enjoy sitting across from someone that
you don't agree with are you saying that
you can do that this is the thing when
you know whenever I see you on YouTube
it says so it so destroys I mean oh my
god it says so it so talks to someone
else yeah big letters you know because
it yeah when you talk to people you
disagree with if they don't get angry at
you and they're not shouting at you you
know you learn a lot of stuff and you
can and and you own your own arguments
and sometimes on occasion you change
your mind I mean I'm a I would say if I
had to place myself in the political
spectrum might be a libertarian but one
of the reasons I changed on abortion
took 20 years but I had an argument with
a guy and I lost it all right and I
thought like you know what I can't
defend my position against this guy yeah
as a great teachable moment it's a real
teachable moment and it reminds you to
listen to people now I like that you
just used the phrase Civic religion
because one of the things I've been
talking about on here is that to me
leftism has become a secular religion
yes I've had a couple people mention
this idea Peter pegasion was on a couple
weeks ago who really explained it well
but that basically the
has become this infallible doctrine that
you must never leave my and if you do
leave you're going to basically have a
fatwa on your head right but a civic
religion is an interesting phrase
because basically you were just your
civic religion in that regard was just
live and let live well we're pretty much
yes amazing and and the idea that you
know that the more government there is
the less people a person there is you
know that the fact that a woman comes
into a town and says oh I know how to do
people's hair and the government says we
need a permit for that we need a permit
to do hair do you know that that's it's
just kind of ongoing if the bald guy
issue right yeah well you know you read
those occasional stories where some
little kid is a lemonade stand every eye
off you know because he was never firm I
mean that is the stuff that is so
offensive to me and it's like I guess
over time I've kept watching people who
told me that they were trying to make
the world more free and more fair but it
always turned out not always but it
often turned out that what they were
really trying to do is take the power
away from someone they felt was
oppressing them and take it themselves
so that they could oppressing a person
who had been oppressing and I have like
just steadfastly maintained that like I
want the world to be more free and more
fair I'm perfectly willing to accept
that somebody's been marginalized and
needs to be included but I'm not willing
to force this other guy to like it or to
include him or to serve him or do
anything else it just seems to me that
freedom is a balance yeah you mentioned
something very briefly about God now
last time you were on yeah we did sort
of your whole evolution which is really
kind of fascinating you were born Jewish
then you were atheist for what a bulk of
your five years were thirty-five Gnostic
atheist yeah and then about how old are
you and you then I was I was about 45
when I became atheist when I start to
believe in God and I was just about 50
when I was baptized and yeah so how I
just had your friend Dennis Prager on oh
yeah my friend Dennis Prager and and
Michael Shermer do you know Michael
mentioned Michael who runs a skeptic
magazine oh yes we had a great
conversation about belief and morality
with God or without that it was really
great at the end we all agreed wow how
nice we can fit
woman not agree on everything and we
might have dinner together you know but
for you as someone that's you know
traveled in and out of religion how
important is the idea of religion as a
foundational belief for society
well the only reason to believe in
religion as far as I'm concerned is
because it's true okay that's the only
reason so the idea that it's good for
society or it is or it conducive to law
and order conducive to politeness and
I'm not interested in believing the
fantasy just because it works and I've
always hated arguments based on
practicality when it comes to
metaphysics significant to me you can be
a nice person obviously without being
without being a theist at all or plenty
of nice atheists lovely people who are
atheist but but I do believe that most
of what you think is true is illogical
without religion without God and many
people don't follow their own thoughts
down to the ground and this is true of
both atheists and believers and I do
believe that here's what I think has
happened to us I think that you know
right around the 17th century that
science became science began with what
we know it today and certain questions
were put aside in order to do science so
in other words you had people saying hey
I can measure this and I can predict
this and then I can heal this and I can
build this and all these things are such
a great you know obviously such a great
benefit to society from the iPhone the
penicillin whatever you're talking about
all this stuff has revolutionized human
life it was assumed and it was argued
that there was an underlying logic to
science which precluded God which
eliminated God even though most of the
people invented science were Christians
it was a presume that there was an
underlying logic so in other words they
say there's evolution and if there's
evolution everything is random and you
go well okay this evolution but random
you can't tell randomness from within a
system you can't say I'm in a system it
is random because obviously the order of
us every system comes from outside the
system
I believe that logic is starting to
collapse I
that logic has played out and I believe
this has been sold to us and the
materialism the basically materialism
that everything is material everything
as a material cost the material
explanation is better than that that I
believe is toxic because it doesn't make
sense
because you cannot get from morality to
materialism and from materialism to
morality that I believe has had a toxic
effect on our society and so I don't
want to replace materialism with theism
because I think it's toxic I want to do
it because I think the truth is healing
and liberating so without going too far
down just specifically the the rabbit
hole of belief we've done it a bunch on
the show and I think I find it even for
atheists and believers everyone kind of
gets to a point where it's like alright
well I
the good ones that you get to a point
where it's like alright well that's what
I believe and it frames some other stuff
so let's talk about that so without
going too far down that rabbit hole if
you think that that those systems are
collapsing is that is that really a
metaphor or or a bridge to why so many
systems seem like they're collapsing
right now yes media politics I think
that's exactly what's happening I I will
sit here and predict to you that I
believe in the next actually I believe
it's happening now but I believe it will
erupt at some point that there's going
to be an intellectual revival of it's
really a risk to Tyrion thought the idea
that we're here we have a purpose and
then that bottle has a purpose that this
body has a purpose this mind has a
purpose that is already coming back and
when you talk to people it's really
interesting when you go in to the top
universities and you talk to young
people there who are the best minds of
the country they're all believers and
I'll believe in God which wouldn't have
been true I think 3040 years ago and
this is because ideas play themselves
out over time and this idea that the
world is material is ending and yes I
think a lot of the craziness we're
saying and it you know I hate talking
about some of these extraordinary
political things because it sounds like
you're being mean like it sounds like
when I say if a man has an operation
then turns himself into a woman he's not
a woman that's a statement of fact in my
to my mind it doesn't be abused or
bullied or
or anything like that so totally
different quota but some of these
questions where reality is starting to
disappear I think are built into the
fact that this idea is collapsing it's
so interesting because I do believe that
trans people exist any mean I'm not
saying a lot yeah I don't think you said
that they don't exist but that but that
I believe that it is it is a actual say
it's a it's an actual existential thing
for this particular rhythm and I think
but yet I can still go with you in that
place because it seems like the hysteria
constantly surrounding it is making
people question everything you know do
you mean like if you don't accept trans
people the second that everyone else
accepts them or not even accepts them
because I think most people except them
but if you don't celebrate it
immediately or wish for an isle it's
like they they will turn on you guys
you're a trend I think of the things
that to give a child to hormone
treatments or any kind of operation
based on some kind of stated preference
that I believe is abusive that I believe
is wrong but for an adult to decide that
he wants to live his life in any way he
wants is only they're not hurting
anybody
it means it means nothing to me I mean
it just means nothing to me but but when
he says to me you must call me a woman
then he's taking away my right to
experience reality as I experience it
and that's where he loses his rights
this is this strikes me as you're sort
of like a mature Republican you know
anyway like that's what it drives me I
was like because everything you just
said makes sense within a conservative
viewpoint yeah you know within a
libertarian conservative viewpoint
except there's so few conservatives
willing to say that what you just said
well you know it's funny you asked me at
the very beginning how I kept hold of
some of these principles and it didn't
occur to me until just a moment ago is
we were taught so I'm like one of these
is I'm a novelist I've lived most of my
life right here animals and when you're
a novel is what you do is you create
characters and each one of these
characters has a full complete existence
and a full complete justification even
when you're inventing the bad guy you
realize that in his mind the world makes
perfect sense and and he makes perfect
sense in that world and I'll actually
think of people that way yeah maybe
that's a novelist training or maybe you
start out with that and it turns you
into a novelist
actually think of people that way I
actually think of somebody who says to
me I'm having this inner experience of
being alienated from my sex or whatever
whatever it is I know that that doesn't
officially be outdone I mean that seems
like I feel it might be painful and it
offends me if he says that I have to
react in a certain way or this guy has
to react by law on a certain way but his
experience is like it really is part of
the kind of fabric of the world and I
think I think that there has been too
many people on both sides have conflated
what government does with how we live so
in other words I've had this argument
with conservatives a lot where they'll
they'll say well they want to legalize
marijuana and I'll say it's fine just
don't let people drive with marijuana
you know and like what you want to
poison yourself I think it's bad for you
but you know it's not my business go
ahead do you think Madeline is that I do
think it's bad for you but what I've
read it's bad for you but I don't use it
so I don't really know that much about a
pen you don't seem to want to stop
someone from you thank you
why would I want to stop somebody from
using it except except if if I were you
I might say Dave you know I've read some
articles not good for you whatever but
then then you know it's coming from me
and you can say whether the vape pen
there's finished that even reserved for
loans come on but this is the thing
government should not have the right to
approve or disapprove it only has the
right to protect me from you it
shouldn't protect me from me if I want
to throw myself off a bridge you know do
I think that's right no but I should be
able to throw myself off a bridge what I
shouldn't be able to do I the best
example I always use is the seatbelts
versus a cell phone you know when you
use a cell phone in a car you're
endangering mate when using it don't use
your seatbelt you want to fly away to a
Hilton none of my business
yeah and then you know I know that
libertarians take some extreme crazy
positions but in general free markets
free minds seems to me the the way
forward so I do see the the freedom
thing gaining traction yes sure even the
way that I've talked a lot obviously
about classical liberalism and
libertarianism and all of this I see
that now I see it I just see it in
society and on social media I see it
more in a cooler fashion that it would
be
we may be coming from Ted Cruz or
something like I see it's gaining a
little traction in a bigger way
I'm not certainly not all because of me
obviously all because you like what you
said about that they'll be an
intellectual resurgence too because I'm
starting to see a little bit of that
that it's starting to feel cool to have
knowledge again as opposed to the 15
years of endless reality TV and just the
worst of us constantly and endless
bickering and one-upping I think we're
starting to turn a corner on that which
which I've been waiting for for a long
time well I mean it's an awful you know
I recently spoke I don't get to speak
too often at places back partly because
I ignore the requests and now now I have
somebody who does it so maybe I'll speak
but I spoke at Oberlin recently which is
a deeply like the heart of liberal
darkness yeah yeah and and and I went in
there and I was I thought that these
children who did my age they now look
like children you know I felt that they
were being almost abused by their
heritage of knowledge of wisdom was
being taken away from them that if you
know you should come out of college you
should read some Shakespeare you know
and you should have read all some of the
great writers you should know some of
these great thinkers Plato and people
like that and you should know them
without the professor standing between
you and the guy you know Shakespeare has
travelled through time four hundred
years to bring you the wisdom you need
vision of the world I don't need a
professor doing anything but explaining
the context to me you know and they have
this thing called fury oldest and on you
know in Oakland there were it was a
black dorm I mean Martin Luther King
would roll over in his grave you know
there was there were kids who showed up
you know kind of aggressively displaying
their sexual proclivities and then
heckling me from the crowd and and I
kept saying you know what hold your
question and I'm going to I'm going to
discuss everything you want to discuss
and then the minute I finished and
talking they ran away yeah you know and
I thought like these are that something
it's just right there you know it
and what was interesting was a lot of
the liberal kids who are just ordinary
liberals they state and we had really
good conversations only the hecklers ran
away yeah and and so I just think these
kids are being deprived of being
deprived of their intellectual heritage
they're being deprived of the idea that
that I can't fix their problems what
they're being told is that they're
unhappy because they be unhappy because
the way I treat them or you treat them
or society treats them they're happy
because of things inside themselves and
then it's a differences this gay guy
yelling at me the whole time and at one
point I mentioned to somebody else in
another context that I was actually a
supporter of gay right and he let out
this loud wolf thank you I said but yeah
I thought people don't like it because
you gave they don't like it a zero loud
yes that's what a collie is all about
that you just want people to be equal so
that you can treat them as shitty as you
feed everybody else I don't want a
special treatment for being gay is like
giving equal treatment and now judge me
accordingly exactly and I think this
this has come you know I see guys like
this tonic I see coats mm-hmm and he
writes these their son you need you need
to be made good for the sins of the past
what a terrible thing to tell a child
nobody can solve the sins of the past
that's the whole point of the past it's
past you know and you cannot fix the
things that we're done to people you
cannot fix history you can't pay people
back for things that happen to people
who dead you know the that's the that's
the tragedy of a fallen world you know
that that things are written into the
fabric of life and to tell somebody that
that he's not going to be happy until he
gets paid back for slavery or whatever
it is it's condemning him to misery yeah
it's a family because it never stops
the payback the payback whatever it is
there's never a moment where you go okay
well we got to where we're supposed to
get and now we don't need anything else
anymore it's just by human logic it
doesn't make sense and this used to be
the question of Education what is the
good life what's conducive to happiness
what does you know what makes you
miserable that used to be what you
discuss and it can't the answer can't be
my happiness depends on you be nice to
me
you're going to be what you are you know
I'm curious what was what group invited
you at Oberlin they some it was a bunch
of Republicans it was like the 15
Republicans yet I won't work I kind of
surprise biggest wanted a 16th guy to
finally show up they were like they were
like trolls you know they were kind of
they wanted me to come and make fun of
the the left and I didn't and I thought
they even though the whole thing
wouldn't be incredibly well I actually
just talked about ideas and people
listened and I thought well that's a
victory right but I felt that the
Conservatives are so sick of being
shouted at that they've just turned into
into trolls they want to mock the other
side yeah which i think is kind of
interesting because I say all the time
but I only get invited now to colleges
by the Young Republicans or the
libertarians and smaller students for
Liberty or Qatar etcetera all of these
things that are technically right even
though they don't they don't seem to
mind them gay married and pro-choice and
against the death penalty and a litany
of other thing and then it's like well
who is the tolerance I die I don't get
any invites from anyone no no Young
Democrats or progressives of tomorrow
have ever called me and been like they
you know we actually see you criticizing
our side but let's come and talk about
it but I'm getting a ton of love from
those other guys who by the way you're
right
there's a lot of trolls in that gentle
baby they've started being the funny
people to that's which is crazy that for
you as a screenwriter and a guide it's
bounced between Hollywood and politics
is that fascinating to you though that
it's why you are starting to become
funny it's a joy I mean I always my joke
used to be that the reason conservatives
aren't funny is because liberals have no
sense of humor but but it is it is a joy
to see conservatives becoming funny and
becoming the people of freedom because
let's face it conservatism in the old
style did have it's oppressive elements
and it did have it's kind of you know
when whenever people are in charge of
the culture as conservatives were until
the 60s basically you know they abuse
that control that's part of that's part
of power corrupting and there was that
element in and there still is among
conservatives that somehow you know you
are destroying the Republic by not being
exactly you know a Bible beating
Christian
whatever it is and and that's just
largely lifted you know I mean so this
is actually the fact that I would say a
positive effect that the 60s revolution
is having conservatives is they to have
loosened up nobody wants to go back to
wearing ties to baseball games nobody
wants to go back to you know a rigid
life where you can't be look you know
take feminism feminism right now to me
like environmentalism is largely the
enemy they are the feminists are insane
they're not about you know actual sexual
relations between people just like the
environmentalists aren't actually about
conservation and all this stuff but
nobody wants to go back to a world where
a woman doesn't that can't choose what
life she wants I mean I always say to
people if you draw a circle it's called
individualism and a circle that's called
feminism in that place with the Venn
diagram meet you know I'll agree with
feminism everything outside of that I
don't agree with but nobody wants to go
back to the world where a woman can't be
fully whoever she wants to be and nobody
wants certainly wants to go back to a
racially segregated world except a left
right they oddly are the ones that are
pushing these things likewise described
at Overland and so and so the modern
right is to some degree a function of
certain things that left this have also
brought to the table and have now become
the party of freedom the party of
hilarity you know I mean you do not
laugh a lot when you're around leftist
and we're not sure when you watch
Samantha be until it's not funny you
know it's not funny it's painful it's
better better Trump being Trump okay I'm
gonna put it in the a right and they
have to brief it of Hipps Oh even if
Polly meant anything to you laughs you
really exciting pockets yeah yeah no
this is this is the funny thing about it
is like it when you hear them doing that
at the cursing and anger in the ring a
lot of laughter so then when you see
people on the right so like a Jeff
Sessions who there's a lot of talk that
he's going to go in and try to close
medical marijuana dispensaries now you
just made it very clear you don't smoke
marijuana you prefer everything being
equal with people didn't for health
reasons I think there's a lot of debate
around that but I'm just going with with
what you said when you see that as a
small government guy
and a states rights guy and a
libertarian that must be the part of the
right that you don't like right yeah I
don't even know why you would bother
with that I mean I I don't know why
there should be medical marijuana
dispensaries why shouldn't just be like
a liquor store you know you can't buy it
if you're not 18 or whatever the proper
age is and you can't use it behind the
wheel of a car and all those things and
then we get the tax taxes you know and
get all that money
so like I don't know why that should be
what's bothering him you know I mean I I
really like Jeff Sessions I'm a pro Jeff
Sessions guy I think he's going to be a
great AG you know I think he's going to
do but are you concerned about that
state stuff because to me that's one of
the biggest issues the states right yeah
absolutely
absolutely and one of the things that's
kind of a joy about the Trump era is all
these liberal states suing the federal
government cuz I think I win that either
way I either win because the federal
government gets the conservative thing
in there or I win because they get
States right so yeah and that's why the
whole that have now been saying every
week I mean the whole chessboard is just
thrown up the traditional left-right
thing barely makes sense it's
authoritarians and libertarians and
allies you know coming together in some
interesting spot I describe it as like
being in a room where the gravity has
gone out of the room and all the
furniture around and you know you don't
know where it's going to land and I
understand some of these guys on
National Review and even my pal Ben
Shapiro you know I understand they're
they're worried about where the
furniture may fall I'm kind of
optimistic and I'm not sure how much of
that is constitutional how much of it is
observational you know right but I do
feel that good things are coming I look
to the generations down the line and
what I see coming up is kind of a
cultural liberalism which I agree with
but but an understanding that freedom
this economic and freedom is
governmental and if the government can
tell you what to like and what to do you
know it's just it's it's not you're not
free yeah and they're not that smart I'm
going to give you a rare choice here do
what do we want to go media first or
Trump first from here this is a
choose-your-own-adventure it's kind of
the same thing let's start with Trump
all right let's go Trump first so when I
hear you talk about Trump so I was with
you on election day actually
we were at the Daily wire offices and it
was me you and and Shapiro and who else
was there and it was a funny night
because we were all having very mixed
emotions I I voted for Garry Johnson I
didn't really want either one of them to
win Ben was alternately like thrilled
and depressed because you know he didn't
vote for Trump buddy but he didn't vote
for Trump did he publicly said who he
voted for and I can't remember yeah I'm
not sure actually you did vote for
something I did vote for coming out of
last minute I made it a very public
decision and I explained my reasons and
all that yeah and and then the fourth
guy that was with us bill little was a
huge Trump supporter and he was talking
about the things that were talked about
now that this whole thing has been
flipped in the biz room like it so since
the election when I watch your videos
you strike me as one of the only people
making any sense either because you
don't strike me as a pure fanboy and
think that he can go out into Fifth
Avenue and shoot someone you might turn
on him there but you also don't strike
me as as just what is what most people
are at the moment which is just this
hysterical lunacy ill-use hilarious I I
write columns a lot of times of pja
media yeah and and I'll say well Trump
has done this right and this wrong I get
this vicious attacks you know you're an
anti Trump ER and I know you're a [ __ ]
whether they give you a [ __ ] you know
and then I go to work and everybody
there who's kind of anti Trump yells at
me for selling myself and I get it from
all sides people always think we're
selling our soul don't know that's in my
people people think if they disagree
with you you're their reasons irrational
your reasons are personal that's what
they think right you're only doing it
for money or for some other reward yeah
where but they do each other it's pure
intellect this is yeah I've gotten them
to the something but you have that in
talega with they're younger than me and
I always think look at them think do you
think it's occurred to me to examine
much ones motive yeah but well that's
that concept though before we go fooling
across that concept of impugning your
intellectual opponents motives I think
it's such a sad thing that seeped into
everything yes sir and it doesn't teach
you I mean there are some people
obviously who were so corrupt that it's
obvious and true but people are trying
to find their way most people in the
middle are trying to find their way so
yeah so Trump okay so make some sense
out of Trump okay well the people that I
voted for Trump because I genuinely
thought that Hillary Clinton was a
threat to the American experiment I mean
I'm not usually talk in those big terms
but she did not believe in free speech
her hatred of the Citizens United ruling
was just indicated to me that she
believed the speech should be controlled
there are four justices on the Supreme
Court who have signed on to a theory of
the First Amendment that says
essentially that it does not guarantee
you the right to speak what it
guarantees is that the government should
control speech so that our values
continue to be upheld
that's a very dangerous sick stupid and
wrong theory one more judge I don't
believe all of them would sign on
everything but one more judge and that
obviously there was an open seat and we
could have lost the First Amendment I
don't believe that was the most likely
thing but it could have happened can you
take the counterpoint on that just just
for devil's advocate the people that
would argue against you on citizens
united well oh well citizens united just
says that if you form a corporation if
you and I form the Reuben Clavin
corporation we don't lose our right to
free speech I mean what happened was
citizens united put out a documentary
against Hillary and they said well
that's campaigning so you can't put it
on the air and they said it's free
speech we can yeah and they said well
you're a corporation so you don't have
the rights in the New York Times signed
on to that the New York Times said no we
are corporation has free speech because
we're a Press corporation but your
corporation does not have you know it's
nuts and that's it's typical of the left
because as I say I believe they're their
reasons their logic is collapsing so
they have to shout you down they can
invite they Rubin to Overland there you
know to talk with the left they can't
because they know their argument is over
so I voted for Trump 5% of my mind and
in my mind 5% I just thinking the guy's
Hitler you know there's a 5% chance I am
making the biggest mistake of my life
and I'm pretty pretty high percentage if
you're going here well you know I
your apps when when Reagan was elected I
remember having friends call me up
saying is this the MSN News he's a good
guy
be fine be on the other side for a lion
you'll die when people call me up like
this I was going like 95% and I think
you know like like you said that's a big
percentage if you're talking a genuine
authoritarian time I I just thought the
bet was worth it because I thought that
Hillary was the end of the American
experiment in the peaceful aspossible
way like you know there's something in
sports called losing comfortably where
you don't even notice you're losing in
the game is over and it's done that's
what I thought she was and and so I
thought it was worth the risk and I had
been largely delighted with how good
he's been now that doesn't mean I think
he's been great it just means that I was
really worried that he was going to be
really bad and instead he's been pretty
good you know
um crazy things about him that are hard
to get over the mean tweets the personal
tweets you know all that so I don't mind
I don't want to mean tweets but but I'll
I'll cave like three things that he has
done that have really lifted me you know
I mean like really just like wow I did
obviously Gorge that's the obvious one I
mean that's a big deal and and people
who on the right who don't like Trump
keep saying you know you keep bringing
up courses I'm going to keep bringing up
but till I'm gone you know that's a big
big Supreme Court I women and he did a
great job it's also kind of a funny one
to diminish regardless of what side your
cuz guess what the courts are a third of
the government that's right that's
that's one of the things your left has
been using them as a super legislature
and of course it won't do that he's
opposed to that the other one and this
is a little wonky of me but I've been I
was talking about a way before the
election so I feel like come by
naturally he's been rolling back
regulations and we were talking about
this before the idea that you need a
permit to get here to be a hairstylist
if a permit to sell lemonade on the
street you know he's been rolling that
back and there was a deluge that was
Obama's kind of you know Parthian shot
as he was leaving office he just left
all these children on regulations in
plays and he's been repealing them and I
think that that is a huge deal the
regulatory state
is a genuine threat to our freedoms you
know just the fact that you know you
need to ask permission of the government
to do anything is a bad thing and that's
to me I mean it really is a really is
uplifting to me yeah and the third thing
and this is what I wanted to talk about
Trump first is that he has driven a
truck into the structure of a corrupt
biased intellectually poisonous media
and it was rotten the structure was
rotten but he's the one who drove the
truck into it and I don't think anybody
else had the charisma or the viciousness
or or the under oath at understanding it
comes from being a TV star to do what he
has done so I'm with you now yeah
especially on that one I like the
regulations also I know this is
somewhere where I have shifted a little
bit right I get it now the government
regulations nonsensical things and you
know as a small business owner I so
understand those type of things now but
that last one to me is the one that's
really resonating with people even the
way you just said it and that's the one
that is catching fire with people and
that's the one that I think really most
people just it just intuitively they
understand do you think he truly truly
got it right from the video think that
really all came from him that's the part
you know I said before the action I just
don't know it is moral centers I still
don't know what like his real sort of
ethos of this managed do you think he
really really understood that like that
was just from being an outsider and
mocked at the old White House press cars
finance things and being on reality TV
and New York media and all that I think
he got it because he's then he's one of
them you know he's like I mean it baby
me too I was a reporter I was in radio
news and all this stuff and I would see
what was going on and how people thought
and how you know when you're surrounded
by people who agree with you you become
biased not I think he's just he's got a
talent for it he's got a talent for you
know I used to talk to Andrew Breitbart
and I would sit there and go like I've
never heard somebody who understands the
flow of information that it's going to
be here at this moment at 12 o'clock I
was going to hear at 2 o'clock I was
going to hear three times this is the
way is going to work Trump's like that
he has a natural genius for
understanding the flow of information
sometimes he will do it'll send out a
tweet and everyone
say why did he distract everybody from
he didn't he realized that he was losing
control of the narrative he seized it
back and because he do that like sit up
in his mount
White House and say aha now at 10 to 12
15 I kind of doubt it for I don't know
him so I don't know but I think he has a
natural feeling for the way this works
and he understands you know it would
keep be a fool not to understand that
he's under fire unfairly and and I think
he knows how to fight back and it's a
pleasure to watch
alright so Trump drives a truck through
this thing I like what has happened
there and we're going to get to that in
CNN in a moment okay but let's talk
about that 5% do you still fear that 5%
or have those fears been allayed just
because time has gone on and you haven't
seen anything that observed they have
been allayed to almost almost entirely
everything that I thought about trunk
turned out to be true in terms of my
assessment of his personality but none
of it turned out to these worst
manifestation so it really did bother me
for instance that he would use violent
language at rallies a punch this guy if
you see that guy punch him in the face
and all that stuff and he does have that
side to his personality but it didn't
manifest itself in in actual violence
right you know he's the opposite of an
authoritarian if you've considered the
fact that one of the most incompetent
parts of his imaginative his
administration is he has been unable to
fill a lot of the positions in the in
the government in the permanent
government he hasn't taken over the
permanent government which is what in
the far an actual authoritarian would do
you know an actual Hitlerian figure
would come in and make sure he made all
the appointments and put his guys in
there he's too lazy to do that because
is that lazy though or is that just a
function of he because there is some
some reason to believe he's just having
trouble getting the right type yeah I
think the day that he probably is having
trouble of his you know he has this
unfortunate habit one of his really
unfortunate habits of wrong footing his
own people so you'll go out and you'll
say well president Trump said this and
he'll say I didn't say that and you get
stabbed in the back by your own guy and
I think a lot of people don't want to
sign on for that he's erratic and he is
emotional and I
think that that's dangerous for the you
know the best people that said he is
appointed a tremendous cabinet I mean an
unbelievable cabinet and a cabinet of
people who are at odds with the agencies
that they are appointed to lead which i
think is part of my hatred of regulation
agency and regulation so when you see
things like so something like the the
Paris climate Accord I suspect you were
fine with us getting I wrote I think
about nonsense yeah nonsense in that it
was non-binding and my wealthy
rightfully that we had to burn in the
loader yeah I think the Paris Accords
were only going to get us into legal
trouble there were only there so people
could sue us there was nothing binding
about it would give a lot of legal
problems to the government and I also
believe the global warming as it's posed
I am NOT saying that the world isn't
getting warmer I'm just saying that
global warming is an hysterical
environmental disaster I'm almost
positive it's a nonsense where do you go
for information on global warming
because this is one of the ones where I
find that when I'm talking to
conservatives and where I know that
there's so much ground to agree on some
stuff that I do believe in in climate
change I would do I would never call it
global warming climate change well the
very fact they changed it to climate
change from global warming tells her
this are today yeah yeah here's the
thing I mean we're on a rock a spiraling
into an atomic explosion it's not a
steady state it's not a it's not a
secure environment we're not living and
we've gone from ice ages to you know
lava the world being basically molten
you know it's I mean the climate changes
so we know the climate is changing we
know it's gotten warmer over the years I
mean there you go back in time there are
years when the Thames froze and that you
know and people skated on the Thames and
so like we know that there's this
changes there is no way to a know how
much of this is human endeavor and and B
to know how much how this goes into the
future when people say science there is
no science for predicting the future
there is no science for predicting the
future when people are telling you
what's going to happen in the future
they are what's coming out of their
mouth is nothing okay when people say
this is what's going to happen ten years
down the line I have arguments like this
about politics too somebody says well if
we do this
and in four years technical like I
stopped Slava right there I go I'll give
you till Thursday and then right you
know I mean well I love that because
every time they show anything that well
the CBO said that in ten years this is
going to cost twenty million lives ever
happens they're always doing this and by
the way you're the same people who got
everything wrong before the election and
now you suddenly can prognosticate
perfect yell and when you hear the
phrase if present trends continue it's
like everything after that is nonsense
because that never happens either you're
right so all right so without it without
getting too far into the climate
changing do you think there's some role
for government to play with dealing with
other nations when it comes to climate
not not I can't think of anything I mean
except like you know III do believe in
preserving our environment and taking
care of things you know this is the
thing is that left always takes these
rational issues where there's a true
good to be gained and they turn them
into hysteria so give us all your power
I mean look I'm a religious guy if a guy
comes on TV and says Jesus is coming
tomorrow unless you send me a check
I get suspicious right but so when these
guys say to me if you don't give the
government all power and essentially
fulfill every socialist need the world
is going to be destroyed in a hail of
fire I feel the same way it's like now
turn on something else
see if there's an old Yogi Berra rerun
on ya which they're easily the garbage
of a really high channel looks like
around 130 years though okay let's talk
about the media now because you because
you can talk about we can talk ourselves
into a Trump style
yes digit spinner and not going to get
it anywhere so the media he drove this
truck through it I do think it's great I
think it's helped voices like yours like
what we're doing here like many other
people who are not promising all the
answers but at least promising
discussions and and some some lines of
thought that maybe weren't getting out
there in the mainstream do you think
that there is a risk in that too that we
are just going to filter ourselves into
oblivion to the point where instead of
having three news channels we're now
going to have a gajillion of them and
we're all going to hate each other for a
zillion new reasons that we didn't even
realize definitely there's a definite
moral hazard here I mean free you know
as as as these lawyers and our press
keep saying a free press is important to
a free society and you do want I mean
another thing that's working well under
Trump is
everybody that the press is attacking
the people in power said what they did
during the Obama administration where
they kept their hands over their eyes
and said Oh lookie scandal-free right i
would argue there's a little bit of an
overcorrection happened an
overcorrection no question about but
that's because they're so corrupt I mean
that's why so I do believe in a I can't
remember the word but I pressed it
basically stands up to power I do
believe there free press we don't have a
free press we have a press that has been
corrupted beyond its purposes and that
doesn't mean they're no good reporters
that means that a good reporter in the
New York Times is basically doing the
wrong thing because he's giving credence
and he's giving credence and credibility
to a sophomoric left-wing college
magazine and with this can you give an
example that because that's the type of
it so I attack CNN all the time I've
seen some bad stuff lately out of the
New York Times yeah
where the headline leads you one way and
then when you read it it really isn't
what it said they've been doing a lot of
Corrections lately which usually no one
reads the correction right you never see
any of that but when I when I do attack
New York Times people give me more [ __ ]
like CNN it's like everyone's been on
the joke okay yeah but but New York
Times it's a little bit different so
when you describe it as a sophomore well
yellow die oh they're I mean if you read
their op-ed page which I now call
knucklehead row you know every their
op-ed page it really is like a bunch of
eight-year-old girls in a room where a
mouse has gotten loose in there all
screaming and yeah I have already run
around this there
and that's really unfair to
eight-year-old girls and if you read I
mean just yesterday they ran a story of
Donald Trump jr. met with a Russian
lawyer and all this who cares I mean who
cares Donald Trump jr. met with a
Russian lawyer to get input because he
thought she had information on the
opposition and everything you know
faints and who can't I saw celebrities
well-known people saying this is it this
is the collusion we've been looking for
it's a penetrate your whole story it's
called opposition research everyone does
that ever you think Hillary didn't get
with people that see if they had
information on Tom and only in an
organization where no one is sitting
next to you who says dude that's not a
story that's a 30 page 30 story only in
a place where everybody thinks we found
the smoking gun can you make a fool of
yourself like that
you know in other words you want
somebody to say to you you know like I
know you're a conservative but there is
something to not letting people starve
to death in the streets oh yeah it's
from out of everything okay it's not
like and the opposite is true you know
yeah I know you're a left winger but
everybody does Oppo research and you
know the fact that she was from Russia
makes doesn't mean a thing you know by
the way as far as I hope he didn't buy
anything from her okay it was a ruse to
get him to talk about this ruling you
know that limits the way they can use
banks and all this stuff I you know
we've been listening to this stupid
story for six months this Russian story
it is not a story I mean it's just not
and even even the Russian meddling with
the election which I believe happened is
kind of like finding a spy you know we
go oh my goodness there's a spy who
would ever spy on a chi you know like
you know can we bring our spies back for
a couple yeah that's what this is like
we do it to them and all this and they
do with us so the New York Times has
become and it's dishonest that they use
good reporters and good reporting to
tell a dishonest story and the fact that
they think that they even can conceive
of the idea that they're not a leftist
rag shows you how far gone they are I
mean that they cannot you know take it
just any day pick up the Wall Street
Journal and pick up the New York Times
and The Wall Street Journal you're
talking to an adult
the New York Times you're talking to a
child well it's interesting that you
made a point of saying the op-ed pages
too because obviously you expect opinion
anyway right so that was that separate
than the editorial side buddy but their
op-ed page the reaction to some of the
things that they're doing has gone
insane so they brought Brad Stevens from
the Wall Street Journal he writes that
one piece basically just about
skepticism didn't even really say he
doesn't believe in climate change like I
think he may have even said the opposite
yeah but then there were immediately
people demanding he be fired and all of
this craziness just for having an
alternate opinion on their op-ed page
but the one that I thought was more
interesting do you see the one a couple
weeks ago about Brett Weinstein from
Evergreen State and it was all about
campus free speech but basically the
thrust of it at the end was we as
liberals better start caring about this
because it's coming for us right but I
thought what a hot admission you you're
now admitting that you didn't care about
free speech because it was coming about
coming against the other people right
now it's finally turning on a guy who
left left left super progressive so now
we better start caring like that was a
strange admission like it was refreshing
I suppose it is but I mean I think the
New York Times has just gone so far down
this hole that an article like that
stands out you know when you read an
article like that in The Times you go
like wow even in the New York Times then
now for free speech you know that's
that's not good you know like in the New
York Times would be for free speech
every day for everyone every day the New
York Times should have conservatives on
on the desks where the news decisions
are being made you know the The Wall
Street Journal is is anti-trump in its
news pages and sometimes unfairly I
think but not crazily you know they have
people obviously correcting their
opinions you know there comes a level
that comes a time when the level of
corruption gets so bad that audacity
becomes a kind of a brag so you see this
in governments all the time you see it
in Illinois places like Chicago and
things like this where remember the the
boss tweed and the little tin box yeah I
put the money in a little tin box a day
shakur up ssin yeah is this is these
comes from a sense that we are so
corrupt that no one can touch us okay
when you put George Stephanopoulos a
Clinton hack at the top of your news
team he is your news guy that's a sign
that you have become corrupt it's not
that he time ABC News yes I say t she
has not not that he's not a nice man or
whatever he is is a guy once said to
Hillary I love you Hillary he can have a
role in your news department but he
should not be running in your news
department the guy at CBS who just looks
like Ted Baxter to me you know the
remember from the viruses in Scott
Pelley yeah Megumi mesogens so biased
during the Obama administration that his
only reporters didn't want their stories
going on his air because they didn't
want to do what I was talking about with
serve a biased report this corruption
has become so manifest and so absurd
that to see it taken down is a beautiful
thing but you're right we need to
replace it with something of value we
need to replace it with something that
works so is that why they're hitting
back so hard so the CNN thing that
happened last week with this threat to
dock
this person who is unbelievably legal
thing it is legal to make means by the
way he didn't make it for Trump Oh
however it got to Trump and it sounds
like it was actually a slightly altered
version we don't know how it is but
there are millions of people making
memes on the Internet as we sit here
right the second it wasn't just that
they were threatening to Docs this guy
for doing something legal
it was the line after that where they
said he's agreed not to do this
offensive blah blah and access their the
church or his parents or something so to
me that was that was the scarier thing
not the threat of the docks which of
course is wrong but the threat that they
were tacitly saying or implicitly saying
to everybody else we're watching you too
and we're going to come for all well you
know that the internet turned on them in
a beautiful fashion ripe and but it was
only the follow-up and the completion of
the logic that went after Joe the
Plumber and of course the right
mishandled that by elevating Joe the
Plumber to some kind of commentator
because he had been attacked but
remember Joe the Plumber went out and
asked the question of a political
candidate and he went after the guy left
a question yeah you know I mean this is
what the hell corrupt they've become and
they are thuggish that and this is all
of them this is I mean I'm talking about
the network's I'm talking about The
Times I'm talking about wopo and I'm
talking about CNN which is and in some
ways the least of them because it's just
a small operation that would vanish like
that if people cut their cable towards
you all right baby what's that thing
they say that if they would get CNN at
airports it would lose like it was all
it's all of its viewers yeah you know
it's all of these guys and and they had
it hasn't even occurred to one of them
not one of them has said well you know
Trump is being a jerk and Trump is not
it's not fair what he does and it's
really wrong when he attacks our
reporter in terms of her face or
whatever you know like but he has a
point
you know we need to reform our industry
there's a reason that the people believe
Donald Trump more than they believe us
as a reason that people hate us so much
so it really is that they've just been
drunk on power
yeah these left whatever it is thirty
years they've been drunk on power for so
long and now they finally have someone
throwing it in their face and now the
people the actual people are rising up
against them to that and I thought
you saw probably Chris Cuomo who of
course his brother is the mayor or the
governor you're one he's another lottery
was the Governor of New York he's an
idiot he's like a Fredo from the corner
ha ha ha he really I mean I every time
you see the guy is just another just
better yeah but he tweeted something
about you know these hateful means and
should we release the information
because the guys tweeted some other ways
i stuff and all that and then he ended
up deleting it but i retweeted him I
said would you say that a meme or a gif
is worse than what then Linda Sarsour
calling for jihad now we talked about it
briefly before we started but regardless
of whether she meant her own personal
jihad but she's talking about the white
supremacists and Islamophobes in the
white house and everyone knows if you're
using that word you're trying to like
gin up a certain something and Mike we
got three more retweets and everything
than any of his do he has a million
followers and almost no interaction
which also tells you a little something
but I bring this up because it's like of
course he doesn't respond because they
think they're beholden to nobody to
where it's like we're but we actually
are beholden to our audience you know
when I was in newspaper man's
newspaperman in a small town with a very
powerful and somewhat corrupt sheriff so
it was like out of a movie you know and
I would I would badger the guy and I
remember saying to why I had some
sources in the department and I remember
saying to one of them look we work for
this we both work for the people and he
turned around they said I work with the
people you work for a corporation and I
thought my god he's right come on I'm
not evil but I threw you know that's it
they don't understand that they're just
mouthpieces for big corporations which
love big government because big
government hurts the little guy you know
that's all there's a standing up for
these powerful corporations in the name
of all the leftists you know by words
and all this stuff you know they really
have lost any real sense of themselves
and it's just it's it's pitiful to watch
in some ways but it is good to see it
getting exposed and what I would like to
see on the right I feel on the right we
have a lot of really good people like
you and me D and Ben and all these
people expressing opinions but we I
don't consider myself part of the right
moving into libertarian yeah I would say
and I'm still a liberal know that which
is a fine line between that and liberty
but yes I hate to even pause you there
to say that but I know a certain amount
of people start screaming but I consider
my more than happy to talk to hell you
go but I say it all the time that I'm a
conservative because I'm Malou yeah all
right so I'll just enjoy a very okay
yeah and and I I think that like I would
like to see us start to gather
information and that's expensive and you
need people to back you and you need to
somehow make it profitable but we need
to start sending people to the hotspots
because for me to get the facts I have
to go to the New York Times and The Wall
Street Journal and CNN and all these
places because they hire reporters and
its opinions are great and insights are
great and there is now because the press
is so corrupt there is an actual need
for people like us to say they're
telling you the facts mean this but the
fact actually might mean this you know
that is an actual profession now it's a
real profession that needs to be done
but I would like to see the right go
after you have people in Iraq have
people in you know in the hot spots of
the world have people in Washington DC
the best news program on television is
Bret Baier special report because they
gather news and because they're fair
even though he's you know even though
they tilt to the right they're very fair
about what they come are you shocked by
the breath of it just sort of the amount
of activists masquerading as journalists
because that's what I think they are
truly these people are not I mean I've
seen just some of the briefs and hit
pieces on me yeah and it's like no
matter how much I plead my case or
defend myself or show them evidence to
the contrary about it you know there's
some Mother Jones calling me and
extremists to the right of Breitbart I
know
yeah and it's real doozie and it's like
you know they just they don't correct
anything they don't care they know their
job is safe and it's like forgetting all
that you're not a journalist like that's
what I tweet a good guy something to
that effect like I just want you to
admit you're not a journalist right wait
write what you want even though I
probably had a decent case reliable
right where you want but can you admit
what you're doing and it's like that
sort of that lack of self-awareness you
know I've been I've now been saying this
to the right for 10-15 years about our
loss of the culture and that's what this
is this is
the result of our loss of the
universities of our loss of TV stations
you know women's magazines every women's
magazine is left-wing every comedian on
television every late-night comedian
every single one there's a left-winger
not one not one and when and when one of
them made a joke was nice to Donald
Trump
he was basically pilloried you know he
had to be found can be found I was the
one yeah it's hard to tell the
difference between all the same you know
they're all exactly right everyone how
do we how did we let that happen and why
don't we respond and I always just I
always say to conservatives that telling
them about the culture is like trying to
explain to my wife when she buy
something on sale it still cost money
and I always looks at me and go and says
you know you're a cute guy I like you
but I don't know what you're talking
about and that's the way conservatives
look at me you know they how did we get
to the point where we have people
talking like a hundred year old men
going I don't go to the movies anymore I
just turn on Turner cloudy and dark
stains good mother you know I mean that
that's insane and how do we get to the
point where we start making stuff that
educates people not to be right-wingers
but simply to just open their minds up
of it so I don't know what your feelings
are on Milo but I suspect after hearing
you say that you must at least love much
of the movement behind them right with
this because isn't he that isn't that
thing that you're now saying we got
we're winning the culture war back I
mean he talked about that all the time
right here you know this is such a great
question it really is a great question
because Milo gives me fits I've only
spoken to Milo once we had a long
conversation about video games he was
when he was on gamergate yeah and and I
like the men you know I mean I got along
with it he has done some stuff that's so
vicious
partly to my friend ben shapiro which I
resent because he's my friend
yeah and anti-semitic and and he's given
given shelter to anti-semites which I
always feel the minute ice min I see
anti some is it is the canary in the
coalmine you know that's where like evil
dwells basically I usually go for the
Jews they go for the Jews first and like
so there's stuff that he's done that I
just think is great
and I wish that he would you know find
himself in a somewhat better place
because there is such a thing even
though I believe everyone should be
allowed to speak there are some things
that are that when spoken or
reprehensible you know so I get over
their consequences fiercely that's right
you know and when I hear him you know I
don't know the June remarks and the and
the kind of the kind of hateful allowing
hatefulness to be cute allowing it to be
ironic saying you know I've heard him
say for instance I prove them say when
when our generation is anti-semitic
they're just being ironical I think like
yeah that's a snake that's going to bite
back you know I don't I don't really buy
into that and and so I'd like what he's
doing I don't always like the way that
he's doing it or what he's doing it in
service to but certainly when he had
whoops of dangerous [ __ ] or yeah I
laughed out loud I thought I want more
of those guys I mean it was bright
bright bright and I used to have this
conversation all the time
you know when I first met Breitbart he
kind of enlisted me into the LA right as
he did almost all of us you know I said
to him I want to tell you right up front
that I'm not going in for this gay stuff
because this anti-gay stuff because I
think we're gonna lose I said we're
gonna lose which is no shame
but we're gonna lose and be wrong and
that's a shame that's really shameful
Breitbart said to me what I want is more
patriotic gay porn
nyami up brother Eskew straight guy is
demanding more how much you people lower
country we're going to watch it but was
really out of it you know and and so I
think that yeah you know I have this
conversation with people about Milo all
the time I see a good as he is doing
I see dangers in the way he's doing it
and I think you can be too ironical
about too much because there is moral
universe you do not want to you didn't
want to blow yourself through it yeah do
you think that's kind of the fasting bar
game that you have to play you're
getting what you want what you've wanted
here and you as a guy that's been
through the Hollywood Machine you so
you're you're getting the culture winds
that really if he had let's say he had
done you know been a little more careful
with his language not done some of the
unnecessary over-the-top stuff or
whatever that it might have
it might have shamed some of the the
good part that you want yeah maybe maybe
just wouldn't have broke through the
game that is that's kind of what the
trump the trumpian bargain I was a
veteran a guy as uncaring about the
niceties would have driven his truck
into the media the way he did and I
think that does it come with moral
hazards yes two people have to speak up
about those moral hazards and take the
flak from the right when they say you
know oh you're a [ __ ] and you hear all
these things yes we have to take that
flak but it has to be done because I
think we had reached a tipping point I
hate to use a cliched phrase like that
but I think we had reached a tipping
point where we were sounding very much
like a communist country like there was
things that you could say it made you
persona non grata that there were
opinions you could have that you know
the trap door that you would like the
James Bond villain you ever thought of
the trap door
I think we were in a dangerous point and
if we and political correctness is a
smothering toxic evil device for making
lying seem like a virtue and if Donald
Trump destroys political correctness
people have done a great thing I mean a
great thing and that it has moral
hazards come along with that I think we
shouldn't forget it you know a good
example of this is when they shut down
Shakespeare in the Park River the other
day
now Shakespeare that was reprehensible
to assassinate the president on stage I
really think you know as a Shakespeare
fan I think that it was a an awful awful
thing to do but they would have done the
same thing if it was Obama right yeah
but to shut them down and to have my
friends you know writing that this was a
good thing you know that that's a
mistake yeah I completely agree because
now what you're saying it's okay to
fight to say well we've got to be as
tough as the left but to say we've got
to be as tough as the left for things
that the left would approve of like
shutting down free speech that doesn't
make any sense to me yeah and that's why
you both and that's why again the side
the side they're just becoming yep
meaningless and nine times I think that
that's a really good observation because
I do think that I and I had this is part
of the problem I have with the right
right now is I keep saying to them you
know you're what
they're disturbed because the
conservative movement has essentially
collapsed and when Trump swept all those
guys off the stage the way he did in the
primaries the conservative movement that
was done for and my response to that is
fix it you know put it back together
differently you know get it's a new
world make a new conservative
conservatism you don't have to get rid
of your principles you don't think it
rid of your big principles but you might
have to get rid of some of the ways
those principles express themselves in
the world yeah so is that just that's
just real politic right I mean it seems
to me here's you're just viewing the
world as it is not as you wanted to be
so if you if you had a guy like like
Bill Kristol where it's like he wants
that conservative thing to exist again
yes I don't think you can make that
happen or you certainly can't it's going
to go through several other iterations
before it was ever to get back to
something like that
yeah no I'm interested in guys like
Henry Olson who are basically saying
pointing out the gradient was kind of an
FDR Democrat more than anything else and
he invented kind of modern conservatism
I'm interested in guys who say look this
is the field of play and this is where
we want to get see this is this is the
thing that I know that I notice a lot of
commentators don't I know where I want
to get I want to get to more freedom I
have more freedom now six months after
the election of Donald Trump seven
months after the election of Donal Trump
than I did eight months ago no question
in my mind the fact that the EPA can't
now rule my sink a waterway and run it
on declare that they can now tell me
whether I can shave or not you know I
think that that makes me more free I
think that being said Trump may not be
great on him in a domain right because
he might want this wall to cut through
with it you know who knows where all
that now but I assure you he would have
no problem using eminent domain to make
a cut no no I shouted yeah no there are
all these dangers involved and so I just
want to see is the ball moving in the
freedom direction all the time and right
now it is and you know I definitely see
moral hazards I definitely look at a
gotta Milo I mean he's in such a good
example because I look at him and there
are things that he does that I make me
laugh out loud and I just think it's
wonderful he's here and then suddenly
he'll say something and I'll think
except I don't want it you don't want to
give credence to hatred and
evil you know I mean it evil evil is
bigger than irony I know we'll eat
ironing you know and so you want to be
careful about that
I feel that that could have been the
ending but I'm gonna I'm going to ask
you one other thing which is do you fear
perhaps that these forces which have
grown so fat and we're so drunk on their
own power and all that now that it's
starting to crumble do you fear that
they will hit back on people like you
and people like me and whoever in a way
that we may don't we may not understand
yet in other words that that bad thing
that they did with the Han [ __ ] solo
and the gif where the meme was a warning
shot only of the way that they're going
to try to treat the people who go
against them well I think we've seen it
with these leaks from the intelligence
community about Donald Trump did this
and they turned out some of those leaks
turned out not to be true but the press
was perfectly happy to say sources
within the intelligence community former
officials and you think well what does a
former official know didn't matter they
were putting a front page that was the
front page in The New York Times The
Washington Post they were that was the
deep State striking back there's no
question about it they're going to
continue to fight this is a genuine
battle this is a genuine battle for you
know I hate to say it but it's a battle
for the future I mean I think that this
global world which has many good things
in it I think the free trade and global
communication or all this also allowed a
small group of people to make decisions
unelected people to make decisions for
for people who had no way to redress
their grievances and I think that that
can't be you know if we're going to
become a global world then I want
America to take it over basically I'm an
imperialist in that regard if the
world's global fine but everybody's
living under the Constitution that's the
way it's going to be if not if
everybody's not living under the
Constitution Saudi Arabia doesn't want
to live under the Constitution then I
want Saudi Arabia to stay in Saudi
Arabia and I want Saudi Arabians to stay
in Saudi Arabia unless they want to come
over here to live under the Constitution
so those are the choices right that's an
interesting way to frame we are there's
a global world run by the Constitution
or America first so I drew a anonymous
source on Capitol Hill I'm telling you
right now
is excellent interview as all talk to
you I hope we can continue the
conversation oh I get my anonymous
source and other hoes from glory
abortion doing quoting this anonymous
like I'm talking to the janitor like who
a source on Capitol if anybody that's
what I want people understand if anybody
it's all made up it's been a pleasure
gonna show you as always and for more on
Andrew check him out on the Andrew
Clavin show brilliant name by the way I
think no it was amazing we worked for
ages on it the Andrew Clavin show it's
right here on the YouTube
[Music]
you